please welcome nicole ari parker karen
pittman and sarita chowdhury
oh my gosh i'm
so excited
[Applause]
i'm sorry i just found myself screaming
like
does that happen to you guys a lot all
the time well yeah i mean i think we
scream all the time we scream yeah
because we've been friends for 30 years
that's right you guys know each other
yes and we did one movie 30 years ago a
little one movie one play one movie one
play and then shared a bicycle shot a
t-shirt
i love that so you have history which is
such a beautiful thing
and just like that
and i'm defined by sex in the city like
i i am that is that is who and what and
how i
in my formative years and so i'm just
on every drop of the show because i am
such a fan and i love it so much and
girlfriends and then i'm meeting you
where you come into this legendary
legacy show and you sweep it off its
feet do you guys feel that
like nicole
are you around enough people to get the
sense that you really are taking this
ball the three of you and running with
it
well i think that it's been a big deal
for them to add three characters of
color four characters of color all
different um and
really tried their best to do to tell
those stories well i mean i think
they've really really uh done a great
job so it's been
you know to join this iconic piece of
television and then to wear these
fabulous clothes and then to be part of
a big change i think it feels really
great yes i just want to echo something
that nicole just talked about about how
thoughtful the writers and producers
have been um with the show not just
bringing out women who we see all the
time in new york city but the nuances of
how these women live their lives is very
specific and i love how lisa todd wexley
lives in this beautiful home um i think
it's on the upper east side with
beautiful art and and and
exciting fashion
but nia wallace is a professor at
columbia university and very clearly
doesn't have a lot of money but it's
very street fashion do you know and of
course there's sema patel who is in the
chocolate mercedes and her family she
meet her family in episode seven right
episode six yeah father and father yes i
love that yeah and
you know they're just very thoughtful
about how they've approached all of it
but definitely nya's arc i have a real
connection to i have two children
but there are some days where i think to
myself man
this is hard harder than i thought it
was going to be and we put motherhood on
a pedestal
and i'm not you know i think they
oversold that they over promised on the
motherhood thing some days you know
i mean
so i think to myself this is a great
it's a great opportunity to talk about
what that is i love that conversation
with you and miranda and the restaurant
so much i just so appreciate it like the
authenticity of it and seema it's true
you come in and i love the scene with
the picture frame
it's like that moment i have chills
everywhere where you're getting to know
someone and there is a major jolt and
how you recover and how you are real
with people i just thought it was so
good
thank you so much you know that scene it
was part of my audition scene really and
i had to do like four scenes for the
audition and i saw that one and i was
like that's the scene and all the others
were the harder scenes in a way like to
smoke and drink my cappuccino and wear
my heels i can't do that but that scene
i was like i know that scene
yeah well how did you prepare for the
role because you say i've heard you say
like i'm not this i'm not that and i'm
like no you are
she really is she really is so the one
thing i don't do is wear heels and i'm
not good at it so when i found out i got
the roll i put on all those heels that
were in the back of my closet i took
them out dusted them put them on and my
embarrassed my daughter because i walked
around the house in heels brushed my
teeth in heels
and
i was very serious about it which is so
and i'm loving you you're in white boots
with like maroon eyeliner and youth is
this taken over are we
killing them
this is for drew
[Music]
you